this isn't just a second amendment issue
it's not just a firearms issue it's an
issue of an overreaching government that
wants to come into your kitchen that
wants to come into your living room and
just see what you're doing hi I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer freeze in TV am here at
Demetri Cara's he's the chief executive
officer of artist Armour in Oceanside
California which recently got rated by
the ATF mitri thank you for talking to
us yeah thanks for having me on
give us the play-by-play of the raid how
did they threaten your business well
what happened was last week they
actually approached us through our legal
council and they requested that we turn
over a product that was that they had
determined to be a firearm and they had
also requested that we turn over a list
of customers to them the penalty for not
doing so as it was explained to me
through our legal counsel was that they
would execute a search warrant against
all of our buildings take all of our
files take everything and make life very
difficult so we went to the the court
system and we asked them for a
restraining order to be placed against
the ATF until the situation could be
figured out we were granted a temporary
restraining order that temporary
restraining order was then later
clarified to include the language that
it did not prohibit them from conducting
lawful criminal investigations the very
next day they executed a search warrant
against all of our buildings and they
proved me right I went to the court
system and I said hey I'm being
threatened I'm being threatened this is
wrong these are not firearms please
let's handle this the right way in court
and let's you know work this issue out
and the response was well we're just
going to come in and actually make good
on those threats that we made towards
you what did they end up taking they
took our computer systems they took the
product that was in question a myriad of
paperwork and you know other items here
in there and talk about the the parts in
general there ar-15 lowers they're
plastic they're easier to produce and
they're person that the serial number
isn't there why do you think that these
parts should be freely sold what they've
said in the past is in regards to the
air 15 eighty percent receivers which
are not firearms is that it's it's a an
object that's in the shape of a receiver
but it hasn't been completed to a point
that it would be considered to be a
firearm is that there's five operations
that need to be left uncompleted that
would have
be completed by the consumer in order
for it to be sold in that stage and the
only real material difference is the
material itself instead of being out of
metal it's out of polymer right and that
brings up an interesting point I mean it
is legal for people to assemble these on
their own and it's also interesting
because these parts I mean people can
print them at home with a 3d printer now
I don't understand why they're targeting
your store this was a nice way for them
to get their arm inside of our business
and grab the information that they're
actually looking for to think that this
is over you know a piece of plastic is
is ludicrous it's ludicrous this
situation was already handled in the
courts there is no need for a raid to
happen I had literally had a meeting
with two of the ATF agents after we'd
had the restraining of the temporary
restraining order granted to us
I took them into the building where the
Palmer Lords were being housed where we
had separated them from the rest of our
inventory and we placed them in a
separate room under lock and key
I offered to hand the key to this room
the only keys in existence to this room
to the ATF agents that were there so
that they would be 100% assured that we
did want this handled in the court
system and that we weren't trying to
pull anything underhanded and divest
ourselves of the product or doing
anything like that there was also a
camera pointed directly at this door and
I offered the ATF if they would like to
have access so they could view this
camera remotely they turned me down on
that as well do you feel like that
you've been singled out or this is more
of a widespread issue on a war on gun
ownership I was offered an
under-the-table deal the only reason
that this has any attention to it is
because I said no I said no I'm not
gonna give you a customer list I'm not
gonna give you this this is wrong what
you're doing is wrong let's handle this
in the court system I can only imagine
how many times business owners are
approached by the government and these
deals are taken and accepted the only
difference in this case is that we said
no and we stood up and they say you know
it's for security reasons but you say
you know privacy is more important than
these alleged security concerns whether
or not they're legitimate as our
founding fathers have said giving up
giving up Liberty Liberty in exchange
for a false pretence of security the way
that we are found in how far we've gone
from our original intention it's it's
unbelievable the fact that they can they
use Gestapo style tactics that
- honest hard-working people the fact
that they you know invade our lives on
every possible level and they just get
away with it they continue on to do this
other than privacy what other issues are
at stake here
they have trampled on the entire Bill of
Rights and again the the question of
privacy versus security I would willing
I would make this argument an armed
society is a civil society so the more
more armed our society is the more civil
it will be and that's my opinion again
but this isn't just a second Amendment
issue it's not just a firearms issue
it's an issue of an overreaching
government that wants to come into your
kitchen that wants to come into your
living room and just see what you're
doing does poke around in there and it's
none of their business what you're doing
in California specifically I mean we
have a lot of excessive gun legislation
can you talk about what it's like to own
a gun shop here I get asked a lot of
times from other people in the industry
why would you operate inside of the
firearms industry in California that
doesn't make any sense this is my home
I'm not going anywhere I'm not getting
pushed out by somebody who's got an
agenda that is contrary to what my
rights are and every time somebody from
you know that the firearms community
leaves California because of the
oppression that's going on here what
you're saying is that well we're losing
one more vote we're going to see one
more vote in that fight every time that
happens and the opposition just gets
stronger and stronger and stronger oh
thank you again absolutely thank you for
even TVM Tracy Oppenheimer
[Music]